[Music]
since 1999 Gallup has asked employed
adults about satisfaction with their
boss or immediate supervisor the first
time they asked this question 82% said
that they were completely or very
satisfied in 2019 a similar 84% gave
this response on the 20 occasions they
have asked this question no more than 7%
have ever told Gallup they were
completely dissatisfied does the bus a
sex matter since 1953 Gallup has asked
people whether they would rather work
for a man or a woman at the time
two-thirds said that they would prefer a
male boss five percent of female and a
quarter said it would make no difference
in 2017 twenty three percent said that
they would prefer a man twenty-one
percent a woman but 55 percent said it
would make no difference finally could
you be the boss do you know more or
could you do a better job than he or she
could in a poll from 2017 thirty six
percent said yes but fifty six percent
said that they didn't feel that way do
you like your boss let us know in our
poll also let us know what other topics
you'd like our scholars to cover in 60
seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI